hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i want to teach you a math trick of how
you can multiply numbers when they are
close to each other
in addition to being a cool math trick
this can actually come in handy once in
a while
when my friend was interviewing for an
investment bank position they actually
asked her one of these questions
and since she knew the trick she was
able to pull off the answer very
impressively
so let's do an example of 17 times 23
how can you figure out the answer in
your head and quickly
we're going to go through the steps
slowly
for this first problem
so the first step is you want to take
the average of the two numbers
the average of 17 and twenty three
is twenty
the next step is you wanna mentally
square that average
so twenty squared is four hundred
the third step is to look at the
difference from the average
17 and 23 are both three away from the
average
we then are going to square that
difference and three squared is 9.
the final step is we're going to take
the square of the average minus the
square of the difference so 400 minus 9
gets us to our answer of 391.
let's do another example
let's do 59 times 61.
we mentally compute the average of 60
then we take the square of 3600
we then look at the difference from the
average which is one
we square that which is also one
and finally we take the difference of
the squares
which gets us to three thousand
five hundred and ninety nine
let's do ninety eight times a hundred
and two
the average is a hundred
which we then square which gets us ten
thousand
the difference from the average is two
squared
is four
and when we take the difference we get
the answer of nine thousand nine hundred
ninety-six
let's do another problem let's do 53
times 55
the average is 54
which we then need to square
this will be tricky most of you don't
know how to do this i actually explained
a trick in a previous video of how to
square numbers in the 50s
so
combining that trick
we'll go ahead and use it the square of
54 is 2916.
the difference from 54 is one
squared is also one
and taking the difference of the squares
gives us the answer of two thousand nine
hundred and fifteen
why does this trick work the reason
i'll give you an algebraic proof
when we're taking a number that's above
and below a number x by y
we're multiplying x plus y times x minus
y
expanding that out we get x squared plus
xy minus xy and minus a y squared
the terms of x y cancel out
leaving us x squared minus y squared
and the x squared is why we square the
average
and the minus y squared is why we
subtract the square of the difference
from the average
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can also support mind your decisions
on patreon
i've made a page where you can subscribe
support the site and get a bunch of cool
rewards
you can also catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker or get my books at amazon